you have a pair to fail treat failure to
handle the failures surviving failure we
are afraid of failing really not afraid
to fail learning from the problems and
mistakes learn from experience failure
to me I'm not scared of it fear is not a
problem in order to be great you know I
mean you have prepared to fail greatly
as well you know it's all about how you
handle the failures you know and I'm
good at handling failures and I'm gonna
handle this
I don't know I'm playing nothing good
hand let's accept your handle failure
bit I gather that sometimes I look back
on it beckon you on where did I get off
going to New York to say that I'm gonna
be an actor no I mean weird but but I
think the thing that's that's really
helped me is to you know a lot of people
when they treat failure as personal kind
of horrendous defeat and really let life
kick them pretty hard and I like to look
at things and say God you know I mean if
it didn't work I want to know why didn't
it work you know why why didn't you know
why didn't it work and really you know
try to lift myself I'm have the courage
to really evaluate it and learn from it
and say you know what happened okay
let's go we should know how to handle
the not only how to handle the success
how to handle the failures but if you
are in the management environment you
water it I want the young people to
understand how to manage the failure
because any task you do you have to come
across problem problem should not become
the captain of the individual or a
project chief and the project chief
should become the captain of the
problems and if it the problem won't
succeed I wrote and directed Pootie Tang
but then didn't the studio lose faith in
you during it that's they sure did yeah
and they chunky wants to film they took
me off well
I already shot it and it was during the
editing process they hated my cut they
let me do they fired my editor got
another guy let me do one more cut Chris
Rock was the star he was one of the
stars yet he read the script he liked it
the I assume the studio read the script
in like yeah it wasn't that a character
that was sort of on the Chris Rock Show
yeah Pootie Tang was a character we did
on the Chris Rock right Chan you worked
on that show and you hated the character
there yeah I'm gonna make a movie about
Pootie Tang well II Chris asked me do
you think there's a movie in that guy
and I said it's not about science I
would have told you know why you're
gonna say yes you wanted to make movies
yeah very badly and so the network that
show was very popular than that I mean
the studio was probably excited about it
or you go out you shoot the thing you
write the thing you do all of it and at
what point is the studio said you listen
you've done here I remember that point
right it was a great moment in my life
because to see you I went to had to be a
brother they could they summon you I got
flown out to LA are you thinking wow
maybe flojet first class I don't even
tell his class I have no idea well I can
I smelled some but yeah they took me to
Paramount y'all those gates it's like
you feel like that you're going the
White House and I went to John Goldman's
office he was Samuel Goldwyn his
grandson he's a good guy yeah yeah and
so I'm in his office I'm in the most
important office at Paramount he was
running the studio at the time and he's
he just he I remember I walked in and
he's shaking a little he was so mad
Manny just unloads everybody was there
that was involved in the movie unloaded
on me and said this movie is
unreleasable you have wasted my money
this is irresponsible I have a problem
with everyone here and then this guy who
was the president of MTV Films they said
well John I don't think you really got
the film how dare you say that
oh it's screaming accompany presidents
cuz my movie there was nothing
redeemable about the way now and not to
him but here's the thing it's a new one
in show business as well that I'll never
forget that moment cuz I feel my whole
all I wanted to do is make movies at the
time and that was being destroyed by
Samuel Goldwyn script you know something
yeah
and I'm sitting there but a part of me
was outside of my body going you are in
the Paramount big office being yelled at
by self cool is really you were able to
yes I was able to enjoy ended into a
logical absolutely because who gets to
have that's very rare beautiful
experience to get to have you know I
read how to make friends and influence
people but for you to have such a
positive attitude as your career well to
me to me that the key is like surviving
failure is a great it just turns you
it's a very great experience
tell me about it nope yeah look I went
through all of that Howard and they
killed you know the press guy me I grew
up watching Siskel and Ebert on PBS you
know anyway was that show and and so I
always dream when I was a kid some day
Roger Ebert and that other dude is dead
or gonna look at me through the camera
and say something about my movie and
here was Roger Ebert saying Pootie Tang
is so bad it I don't even understand
what it is this isn't even a movie it's
not even complete huge Anna yeah right
he's like why don't they shoot the
director yeah he was like so hateful and
I'm having the experience of becoming
famous for making a movie everyone
unanimously thinks is awful a lot of the
time we do have good ideas but we are
afraid of failing I think especially for
women and I see that in my daughters in
my daughter's friends fear failure is
what stops us more than anything yeah I
agree
and I was like in that I had a mother
who M was full of sort of this
colloquial wisdom and she used to say to
me you know failure is not the opposite
of success it's a stepping stone to
success there is nobody who has not
failed along the way so I think it's
very important for young women
especially as they are starting in life
and to recognize that because otherwise
they only see people's successes so I
when I speak I speak of my failures I
had always wanted to be a lawyer and I
basically failed the LSAT I'm a terrible
test taker and that was a devastating
moment for me but what I quickly
realized was that failure is nothing
more than life's way of nudging you and
letting you know you're a little bit off
course and Spanx would not exist if I
had not failed or basically found the
elf that I also was raised by my parents
my dad had this thing that he did when
we were little and it made me realize
that I'm really not afraid to fail at
all my biggest fear would be to not try
something and my dad when we were young
my brother and me we'd sit at the dining
room table at night and he would say
what did you guys fail it this week and
if we didn't have something he'd be
basically disappointed and it was
complete reverse psychology but it was
brilliant because it caused my brother
and me to try out for things we didn't
think we'd be good at and it made us
less fearful to go outside of our
comfort zone I think you might agree
that we learn more from our failures
than our successes okay well there's
been so many challenges that we've had
and I think I think you know one thing I
talked to my team a lot about is during
those challenges you have to really be a
leader and you have to lead with
conviction
so the toughest times which I've been
through many I mean I can just say one
time we were changing systems and we
didn't back up anything properly it was
maybe six years ago it was a huge
mistake so it was when social media is
really taking off we were just starting
Twitter and everything but it was maybe
a six month problem and we had to make
the decision to be authentic and really
talk about it with our customer and or
not and the great thing is with with
social media transparency is super
important and being authentic and just
in general that's how our companies set
up but to have the two so we we decided
to do that it was it took us maybe eight
months to get out of a really bad place
of going to New Jersey packing up packs
boxes ourselves and you want everyone on
our team I'm sure some people over there
including myself on Sunday nights at
2:00 in the morning would be packing and
shipping boxes and we had no visibility
so that was a perfect but that said we
learn from it we now have
really good systems going in working
with s AP which is a lot of fun and so
there's been so many but but I think
it's really learning from the problems
and mistakes is really the telling part
it's how you go forward many of you
already have dealt with some very
difficult times so this is no different
than some of you already dealt with when
you fail it's okay to get depressed it's
okay to cry it's okay to go home it's
okay to blame others for a while but
eventually you have to get over it and
move on the greatest people have ever
walked this planet and if I'm talking
I'm not talking business people I'm
talking about people like Nelson Mandela
and Abe Lincoln constantly had setbacks
in life and failures constantly all the
time in business and some of your
success will be how you deal with the
failure not how you deal with the
success when I get introduced I always
get introduced that 1998 I was the
president of Citigroup and in 2000 I
took over Bank 1 I was fired in 1998 so
I went a little bit of experience like
this and it's a painful thing my boss
had worked for 15 years called me in and
said we want you to resign which I said
ok I went home I told my wife and
children I called my wife up and said
Judy I'm going to tell you something I'm
not kidding I always make jokes about
things like that
but I wanted to make sure the kids were
fine I went home my three wonderful
daughters they were much younger than I
said the oldest youngest one said dad do
we have to sleep on the streets
I said no hon were okay the middle one
who just graduated Barnard said dad can
I still go to college
I suggest you you can and I knew things
were fine when the oldest one was going
to Harvard Business School said dad I
have that little cell phone you have you
won't be needing it
I remind people when you fail at
something it's your I told you about
Citigroup is my net worth not my
self-worth and I was able to move on and
yes it was difficult I did call my boss
a year later he did not call me I called
him and said it's time to break bread we
went to lunch together I told them the
identity did the right thing for
Citigroup which is pretty obvious at
this point but but I told him the
mistakes I made and what was 40 60 or 60
40 wasn't important I wanted to learn
from the experience and move on failure
to me I'm not scared of it because it
just gives me the opportunity to for
change I think change is very good
regardless in what shape or form it
comes into it because it makes you
really observant reorganize and rethink
your life I've got their achievements
that aren't that big what all know and
fear is not a problem how you deal with
a problem and if you don't deal with it
then you'll feel again I always feel
that adversity is always driving
Manchester nated on we don'twe losing
and therefore the human beings we've
going near that character we've got in
the dress room has to come to the
surface and moments where we've lost
again thank you guys so much for
watching I'd love to know what you
thought of the clips which one was your
favorite what impact is it going to have
on your life on your business leave it
in the comments below and I'll join the
discussion thank you again for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon